[Music]
in the film that we're going to talk
about fruitful station you had uh a
beard
but you said that it it took you and and
not even a just a little more than you
have now we don't have to like we don't
have to bring that up right now
well i'm going to because i'm fascinated
by this topic but you but but i read
somewhere that you
you had trouble growing the beard it
took a while i can't i can't um i can't
grow a beard i can't really connect
i mean it's a little patchy
there are parts where it doesn't grow
and andy has that problem don't you all
right that i can grow it here and then
there's a few hairs waving down there
i mean women i mean doesn't don't guys
do everything for women for the most
part yes everything
everything that i did for the first 30
years of my 30 40 years of my life was
all designed towards getting a woman
today all right so i hear that
during my research you know in my you
know my teenage years you know women
like that little stubble that that new
growth that dangerous look that you know
he might choke me up i don't know
and i i i can never no they like that
they like that i i couldn't i couldn't i
couldn't pull that look off so i have to
i had this is all i can do they should
make a spray they put stubble on your
face you got a beard just stubble there
should be a stubble spray i'm i'm i'm
patting that i'm taking that actually
now what about your back you got a lot
of hair on the back
no no i don't no no i don't hear it i
have hair nowhere in my body except my
back oh really yeah
just a strip down the existing question
mark no one understands what's going on
not the landing strip on the back i
don't want to talk about this anymore uh
[Music]
um
i gotta change tone now but for good
reason uh fruitvale station uh this is
an extremely powerful movie uh you are
brilliant in the film thank you so much
uh and um it is a it is a
true story
uh and and it's it it took place in 2009
2009 yeah between oakland 2009 true
story and well why don't you set it up
because it's such a powerful story oscar
grant oscar grant this kid from uh from
oakland california he was handcuffed
face down shot in the back by the bart
transit police on new year's day and the
movie takes place over the last 24 hours
of his life it was a very eventful day
it was his mom's birthday it was new
year's and he spent a lot of time with
the people that he really cared about
his daughter his girlfriend and all of
his best friends
and um
you know
it's a i love ryan coogler's approach to
the to the film because the director
the writer director because it gives you
the day in the life of you know um
sometimes you know when these incidents
happen all the time they're a blurb in
the newspaper you don't really know much
about the person whatsoever you know but
this this way you spend a day in the
life of you know if i could wake up in
the morning with you and spend the
entire day go out there go throughout
your daily routine i can get a pretty
good idea of who you are as a person and
your character and that's what you
should be judged on well well what i
thought is exactly what you're saying
the movie begins it's quite powerful but
there were witnesses there who had their
cell phones out and they were recording
who are recording it and so you see this
young man and a few other young men
being detained and then you see this
whole thing happen very shocking things
get out of control quickly um and then
as you said it's a story in the news and
sadly a story
we hear too often exactly
what hap what happens then is you guys
make the me the viewer and anyone who
watches the movie
get to know oscar grant as a person as a
person and you really care about them to
the point where at the end of the movie
i had to go back and just went back to
see
the the documentary footage at the very
beginning and it it just made it's so
powerful it's so powerful we're so well
done thank you you are brilliant in this
movie uh we have a clip here from uh
fruitvale station i think this is uh
a fight that takes place on the bart
line the train right before uh right
before the it precipitates uh all the
trouble afterwards let's take a look
hey
hey oscar
hey
katie from the store
hey hey
how are you i'm good i'm good happy new
year
oscar from pharmacia
oscar what's up hey peter get
christmassy
all right